Welcome to the Real Spoilers Podcast I'm
your host Paul from heavy spoilers
joined by none other than Greg from real
rejects West we've decided to start a
brand new podcast you know we're both in
our 30s so the next logical steps to
make a podcast
um and every week we're going to be
going through the movie news TV news
giving our opinions and just having you
know a bit of a chat I want this to
basically become like Good Morning
America or good morning England where
you guys at home you know you're on the
commute you go into work or you're
sitting in bed at night with her nothing
to do you want some soothing voices to
to make you go to sleep then we're here
for you to talk about all the all the
news of the week keep you up to date and
you know just have have a great time and
me and Greg will wanted to do a podcast
for for quite a while now
um we're we're working with together on
xero Edition which I'm wearing the
t-shirt for uh Greg's wearing his which
has sold a hell of a lot more than mine
so yeah either go by his which is much
better or go somewhere so yeah but uh
yeah we just just thought we'd kind of
come together for this podcast and talk
about things in the week because we're
both you know there's so many things to
cover at the moment
um and we we don't really have the time
to do massive in-depth videos on them so
take the latest the laziest way out
possible and just have a conversation
every week going over it we have got
some good stuff to talk about though
um and first off let's get into the
flash reactions Now Greg you were you
were booked to go see the flash last
night and they canceled my ass they
canceled me
and what and this is how much of a cope
it was Greg was trying to seem like
really cool like oh yeah it's not
because it's me they canceled it they
they also invited Kevin Smith and he he
got told he couldn't go either yeah
whatever mate yeah it's fine if you if
he didn't get invited because Warner
Brothers I don't want you to look less
of me Paul I am I want you to know that
Kevin Smith also did not get invited
I mean how does it feel seeing those
reactions
yeah I now I know what it's like to be
on the end when everyone [__] at me
on social media we're like why did you
get it Go Greg and I'm like well we got
a YouTube channel that does really well
and then I see other people going I'm
like why did they get it go why didn't
Uncle Mike couldn't get into that same
event yeah I think so what happens in
these with these screenings is they
invite a lot of people because they
think that some people are just gonna
say no like not to brag mate but I get
I'll get bloody invited screenings all
the time but they're always down in
London and it's like the UK screenings
are always normally the week of
um and in the case I think it was
Guardians of the Galaxy it was the
Tuesday that it it was the screening was
on the Tuesday the Wednesday morning was
when the movie was coming out
um at like 9 A.M so I just thought like
you know I've got it's it's like a six
hour round trip to get to London for me
so I just uh just give that a place to
Greg from real rejects he needs to
bother me uh but no you you get to go to
quite a lot of the premiere so I was
quite surprised at that I mean every
time I mean you met like Karen Gillen
and stuff and I was quite jealous about
that
yeah you know you take a good photo and
it makes it look like that you're having
the time of your life out of Premiere
but really A lot of the time premieres
I'm just waiting around for the movie to
start and I'm getting impatient and you
know like I take I don't like socialize
with these guys for a long period of
time I'm always from the mindset that
they're not gonna remember me at all
yeah so I'm gonna give my compliment
although Kamala Khan um Iman villani she
knew who we were and that was that was a
real honor but the like Karen gillen's
not gonna remember us I'm like I'm just
gonna take this photo and everyone's
gonna be like Greg you're living here
life man so yeah
oh it's cool but so so flash was last
night
um reactions are seeming very very
positive that is kind of you know I've
noticed that kind of doing a bit of
marketing with the screenings because
they haven't shown the post credit
scenes
um and I heard from someone who went to
see it that the people were like oh mate
you're going to want to come back for
the post credit scene and they didn't
out and out say what it was but
from what I hear the point they cut it
they're gonna be bringing quite a big
actor who is well we don't know who the
actor is but they're bringing in a big
character into the scene it's what they
see the end of the movie sets up this
big character's arrival
um and then you know they cut from there
all right so am I breaking embargo here
I don't know I'm weirdly okay with
hearing rumors about a post-credits
scene I like yeah
yeah no one knows what it is okay so you
don't know at all like who it might they
didn't show it no they didn't show it no
they didn't show anything so no post
credit scene I'm sure they said
you're gonna have to come back and see
what happens next when the movie
releases so come watch it again which is
quite clever marketing it's because
well we've seen yeah we've succeed with
some studios that I don't really care
about letting people know what happens
in the post-credits scene Dwayne Johnson
being a big proponent of this spoiled
fast X spoiled Black Adam
um obviously variety spoiled um
Harry Styles arrival oh yeah so
um I think Warner Brothers are kind of
being smart with the marketing here and
saying if you want to you can come to
the screen and travel that six hour
round trip but we're not gonna show the
full movie so yeah it is quite a smart
thing um but the reactions are really
positive you know some of the reactions
do tend to be quite positive in general
a lot of the time
um like we know someone who went to see
Ant-Man in the WASP Quantum Mania
didn't really like it but they said nice
things about it on social media because
and I'm not saying that's like you know
that I hate that person who did it but
the way the reactions are geared is to
to more kind of promote the positive
aspects of the film because if they were
allowing reviews they just let reviews
go up at the same time but they have the
reaction embargo earlier because it's
more kind of like uh people are
genuinely like you know coming out the
other movie experience you do tend to be
more positive
um and then it's when you sit down and
think about when you start writing that
review you know I'm not putting like 20
hours thought into a tweet saying and
this movie was good
um so yeah I can kind of see why they've
done it well I've been to a lot of these
screenings and premieres and admittedly
I've had it happen a couple of times for
me where a premise it's hap I've been
able to
um disassociate my feelings enough like
separate from what the crowd is feeling
to what I'm feeling I've gotten much
better at that of just going what am I
feeling instead of just responding to
the crowd Thor 11 Thunder was the
ultimate test for me when I was like wow
that I watch it with the premiere
everyone was like hooting and hollering
the whole time and having like the a
ball of a time so I I walked out like
all right this movie must be awesome
this is an awesome movie and then when I
re-watched it it was a smaller crowd I
was like oh there's a lot of problems
with this movie actually yeah and and I
like when I saw Shazam for the gods I
was able to separate myself from the
crowd and that was a real like knowing
experience for me of people when they go
to premieres a lot of the time the whole
hype in it it's not it's different than
just going to a screening like a
pre-screening a Premiere is like a
celebration of the release we are all
going to watch this movie so people are
going to be cheering during the credits
like a names drop it happens
all the time so it can be it can be a
bit manipulative uh on that front the
thing with the flash that's weird is
like I haven't seen a movie that just
gets so many random celebrity
endorsements um all around you know you
got like apparently Tom Cruise got
Stephen King like yeah but then Stephen
King I thought about it he there's Andy
muschetti who did it and I know he was I
don't know if there's like some kind of
thing where he has to be nice but yeah I
think uh
[__] [__] Stephen King Stephen King
famously saw Stanley Kubrick's The
Shining and it was it was like this is
[__] mate this is [__] if he'd had
Twitter back then I don't think the
reaction to The Shining would have been
a positive one
um but he's came out he said this is
good and I believe him
um but yeah it's but the reactions are
mostly positive like the the way I've
kind of been with things is with
reactions lately is I I take them with a
pinch of salt
um and it was purely because of you know
some movies that are released recently
that have got such good reactions and
then the reviews drop and it's like wow
which we'll talk about one of those
films in a while where they their
reactions dropped and then the Rotten
Tomatoes score dropped as well and it
doesn't look good for Indiana Jones
we'll say no and but yeah that this The
Flash The Flash seems pretty positive
and they are screaming it quite a lot
like almost everyone knows somewhere
I I think the one thing I mean the last
thing I think I'd say about it is what
I've noticed too because we were
mentioning that there's some I know a
few people when it came to quantumania
who were bitching about the movie when
it was done and then I would go to their
Twitter and it's nothing but praise I
think beyond the fact that some people
have this preconceived notion which is
totally [__] like I've talked to the
Disney publicist before he's like I
don't care if you don't like the movie
or not just don't spoil it he's been
very specific about it like you can be
as mean as you want just don't spoil it
and I still get invited back even when I
am mean about a movie uh I I think some
people they have that thought and the
other thought is that I think people are
scared of of comic book fans especially
of disliking something and feeling the
vitriol because a lot of people have
sold themselves on whether or not they
actually like the movie before they've
seen it and there are people get afraid
to deal with the backlash like
quantumania was one of the I wasn't the
first but I was like one of the early
people to be like I don't know about
this movie guys and then yeah a peep ton
of backlash over people who hadn't even
seen it and then sure enough as the
reviews start piling on the more people
started seeing it and disliking it so
then I was like okay I'm now not alone
but in the beginning it was like Yep
this is just as I anticipated I'm gonna
get a bunch of crap for disliking a
movie yeah just because it's a comic
book movie and I think that you know
everyone kind of has imposter syndrome
as well a lot of the time
um like I've got to the point now where
I'll just stick to my guns and if I
don't like it I'll say it like like the
amount of Disney plus episodes that
we'll watch together and text each other
immediately after saying this was
terrible or this was great but I can see
when you we're first starting out you're
getting invited to these screenings and
stuff and you say you know you think uh
this isn't that good and then you see
everyone else saying this is the best
movie I've ever seen it's awesome I can
see when you you're not that confident
in your opinion that you might be like
well maybe I messed up and I don't want
to say this movie's terrible so I'll
just go with the crowd on it and but a
lot of the reactions to the flash that
I'm seeing are people who aren't
necessarily critics and don't
necessarily go with the crowd like
you've said Tom Cruise
um Stephen King the like the person who
who spoke to me about it he's not a
crick he just happened to be in
attendance at the the cinema when they
showed it
um and yeah it is the criticisms I've
heard are that the third act kind of
you know devolves into your
stereotypical
big action set piece superhero Thing
um which you know you can kind of expect
uh but they've said Michael Keaton's
brilliant in it
um
Chris from 3C films today he talked a
bit about the opening of the film and
and he said that it felt like they
finally
got the whole Justice League stuff down
and they obviously the trailers have
shown us quite a lot and they said he
said the Ben Affleck thing at the
beginning felt like all these storylines
that have been building for the last 10
years finally came together and worked
with a Justice League that was really
well formed and working as a cohesive
unit wow
um Ezra Miller is getting lots of Praise
as well and I think a lot of the reviews
I've seen come with the caveat of well I
can't condone some of the things that
Ezra Mill has done but
they make a really great
Flash in this film
um and it's it's kind of it's a bit of a
weird film I think when you think about
it because
you know the Snyder versus pretty much
no more
um
but it feels like it's going to be a
celebration of that and it's also a
celebration of Tim Burton's Batman
and then at the end it's going to be
like
well we hope you enjoyed that because
that's the last you're gonna see of it
never coming back we're going to the DCU
which is right with the post-credits
scene is supposed to be for is
just pops up on screen and goes well
hope you guys enjoyed that because we're
burning it all down and then he just
walks into like the Warner Brothers
archive where all the films kept and
just strikes a match and just all goes
to the trailer for Creature Commandos
yeah sure this is what you're getting an
animated movie a show starring Frank
Grillo who I want to talk about later
because he said something quite
interesting and but yeah flash reactions
genuinely positive I am excited to see
it
um I think it's got a good chance of
being the best live action comic book
movie of the year I think across the
spider-verse will probably be the best
one
um but I mean Warner Brothers need a win
as well after this because they've had
so much stuff like
it got to the point where I was just
thinking how how you know how can Warner
Brothers just keep going because they're
just taking L after L and there's so
much controversy around them even James
Gunn getting hired uh and then obviously
all this stuff that happened when he you
know got rid of Henry Cavill and stuff I
know people are like well technically
didn't get rid of him because he never
hired him but
they had a post credit scene with them
at the end of Black Adam and then he'd
go posted an Instagram story saying I'm
back and then two weeks later I was like
well sorry guys uh turns out I'm not
back
um so we'll see your game of semantics
that James Gunn was playing at the time
yeah and and the Flash especially as
well I mean how many years has that been
in development
yeah this is an odd year man I mean like
we were briefly talking about it like we
had the pandemic which created this
whole crazy schedule issue and filming
problems and and then this year it's
like we got Jonathan Majors which is
he's very happy there's a strike
happening right now which is just
causing more delays and then people
being fired and then the flash is
finally coming out a movie that's been
countlessly delayed and this is it and
like while they're trying to get the DCU
like we're finally doing it but I think
on the rider strike which is preventing
them from actually evolving the DCU even
more it's a it's a very very odd couple
years for Cinema in general yeah
definitely it's it can be worrying as
well like we have to do this full time
and I tell you the stress of um 2020
especially knowing that we were you know
I I quit my job in November 2019
and uh to do this full-time and I was
thinking guys we're going to the bank
it's gonna be crazy and then the
pandemic hits and you know what the the
anxiety of just being like how the hell
am I gonna make it through this month
every single month knowing there's not a
movie coming out and I remember tenet
got delayed and
then it I'll like build myself up
thinking well if I can make it to tenet
I'll be fine and then I remember being
out on a walk
um next to my house and I checked my
phone and it said tenant delay it again
and literally my heart I just felt my
heart sink
um because it was so bad and I think you
know the writer strike is probably going
to have a knock-on effect with us
um
there's gonna be lots of different
things and that's kind of why we've
started the podcast as well because we
just want like steady content over this
he's trying times they obviously we're
not going through the bad stuff yet and
we just talk about the content it's
obviously the writers and the studios
we've got to sort of all that stuff out
I'm not trying to be like I'm the victim
in all of this yeah you are you know
you're 100 victim
because I've got a victim mentality
built in I mean uh just look at my face
I want everyone to know that every month
Paul's like if I can just make it to
this release date of this movie looking
at his channel you're doing fine Paul
you're doing better than most people I
know and myself included you into you
reviewed RoboCop yesterday
RoboCop it'll buy now I see your videos
here you have these breakdowns that are
like oh it's a dead and then suddenly
like a week later like it's blowing up
it's doing great biggest video on the
internet
but yeah tell you who else is having a
nightmare
now we aren't the type of people who
make videos saying Kathleen Kennedy
deserves to be fired and but we'll just
go through them so much better though if
we did oh my God the easy views yeah
well once the strike hits and we've got
no content I'm Every Day I'm making a
Kathleen Kennedy getting fired video
virtue signaling up the Wazoo up in
Disney that's what we're gonna we just
gotta say a few keywords virtue
signaling what culture
pandering what else is there there's
another one I'm missing identity
politics sjws
yeah and never give context to it other
than just say it a few times yeah but
saying all that I mean it's looking at
that point now where Kathleen Kennedy I
am starting to think
uh is it time to go
let's go through what happened just last
week just last week right and this I
think this is all in one day as well
um so Willow got removed from Disney
plus the Star Wars Park thing that
closed down Mandalorian season 4's
delayed because of the writer's strike
Indiana Jones what Star War I I totally
missed the Star Wars Park thing what are
you talking oh the hotel one the cruiser
yeah oh yeah the one that looked like
the prison from Andor got yeah
well it's like five grand a cocktail
there was like a five thousand dollar
cocktail error or something isn't there
like some crazy like kind of Crystal
cocktail where you pay five thousand
dollars for a drink and I bet it doesn't
even get you drunk I bet I put my life
on that I bet it's not got absinthe or
anything I bet it's just like one shot
of vodka and
some baby Yoda crap around the side and
that's what they're charging you for but
so yeah Willow removed from Disney plus
the Star Wars Park thing closed down
Mandalorian season 4 delayed because of
the writers strike Indiana Jones Show
shown at cans debuts as rotten on Rotten
Tomatoes with I think the score dropped
down to 33 and IGN gave it a 4 out of
ten now I'm we're not like well actually
I know the gospel
I've said on the channel quite a lot you
can't say ignorant without IGN
um but then normally I mean those guys
are normally seven out of 10 every film
yeah but even without them still I I
think it's still rotten on Rotten
Tomatoes The Score has gone up a bit you
know everyone's like
whenever you bring up scores on Rotten
Tomatoes people are obviously going to
the the classic well Rotten Tomatoes
doesn't matter blubber but it does like
it does you might not agree with it or
pay attention to it but it's you
everyone must admit that the score and
it matters because as soon as that score
comes out whether it's good or bad it
always dominates the conversation for at
least the first couple of days and many
years after when people are arguing
about it's still on Twitter they're like
well how can you say this movie's bad it
got 63 on Rotten Tomatoes see people
love it but yeah all that coming
together I mean what a bad week so
let's start at the beginning Willow
removed from Disney plus along with the
movie now people were like well Batgirl
got removed the difference is yeah
Batgirl was canceled as a tax write-off
you can't get a tax right off for Willow
because it's been released
um and I just I I still don't get the
idea behind releasing Willow I mean me
you Ryan Airy Philip Molina
we're all in a big group chat and I
remember just before the willow show got
released we were all like why why why
have they made Willow I mean it's like a
40 year old movie I'm pretty sure it's
got a Rotten Tomatoes score as well
doesn't have a massive following doesn't
have an A-list cast member that that
they got back for it
it would and I remember saying at the
time
odd Disney like have they run out of so
many ideas that they're now scraping the
barrel with Willow now if you're a
willow fan yet I don't hate you we're
glad to have you
um but you must admit there's not it was
never going to be a massive hit and I I
used to take the mick out of Ryan Airy
because he was covering it and then he
stopped one day because the views were
so bad on it that he was actually you
know the the channel was losing money
from covering it and he was constantly
getting comments saying
why did you guys stop covering Willow
and he's never gonna come out and be
like because it just cost too much money
to we're losing it because the show's
not popular enough but I I was texting
every single day going why did you stop
covering Willow right agents yeah so
what were your thoughts on Willow
uh I didn't bother to watch it at all uh
yeah I had no interest I don't even
think I've seen the original movie
I've I've heard it
I've heard it's good but the fan base
around it it was just one of those
things where you can tell that that's
these are a lot of people I I think uh
I think especially on my end it might
not look like what with like putting
together an episode reaction that
actually takes
quite a quite a bit of time to like yeah
it's a lot of hours and and but from the
outs but the point of my videos is it's
supposed to look like there's no work
going in like that's the big part of my
videos I'm supposed to look at yeah but
really the the whole assembly process is
very time consuming and yeah I didn't
bother to cover Willow I I am surprised
by because when I look through the list
I was looking through the list while you
were talking and I was I was typically
paying attention the entire time Paul
um I've talked far too much on this
podcast by the way you can you'll find
to integrate I it's harder to interrupt
when we are
um internet talking to each other
because I'm like what is the lag here on
an interruption uh so that's why you
know we'll figure it out
blah blah
and it's either going to be Paul talks
too much or Greg is way too quiet on
this podcast it's going to be one of the
two responses uh but Willow is the one
that surprised me because they've
promoted the [__] out of that they
threws down so much money to not only
put it together but they really really
promoted it they really wanted eyes on
this thing and then to
like hide it in their there's a thing
called like a Disney Vault isn't there
is it yeah I don't know if Like a Star
Wars holiday special belongs in that
result now yeah so so what they used to
do was they'd release movies
um on like VHS or DVD or something
um and they'd then put them in the
Disney Vault where they just stop
producing them you couldn't get your
hands on them and it was I think the
weekly Planet talked about it this week
as well
um go check out their podcast but it
created this artificial scarcity where
when they re-released it you're like oh
[__] [__] and you know I buy a lot of
4ks I buy a hell of a lot of 4K Blu-rays
like maybe two a week and I'm always
looking for titles to be released on it
so I totally get why they did it
but the thing is with streaming is that
I don't know if you can really remove it
and and create the scarcity especially
now with the internet I mean you can
probably download anything that you want
um whereas back in the past when you had
to buy physical media you had to get
your hands on it
um whereas I don't think they can really
do that anymore and there's no physical
media for any of these I think the
I think it's [__] like what's happening
for everyone does it mean yeah that it's
been out yet no God no I don't think
it's anywhere near wasn't it this year
when it came out I am my recollection no
it must have been before Mandalorian
um my recollection of I don't think it's
been a year though but I think Beyond
Willow it's like every one of the shows
you know like there's a big part of the
rider strike it one of the elements of
the writer strike has to do with how you
know writers and creators are paid when
it comes to doing a streamer you know
and one of the compensation factors is
well you know even if it doesn't get
renewed because there's a lot of shows
that will go on network television never
to see the light of day again that get
canceled after a few episodes and you
never get to see it I have tried finding
the follow-up to friends Joey countless
times and I cannot get my hands on a
property
um crazy I haven't tried the torrent
bird out of all the I want to get like a
DVD copy at least yeah but for these
guys you know they already get paid [__]
uh for at least most of them they get
paid [__] and the the one thing they can
be at least guaranteed is ah at least we
get like the permanent exposure for it
to be up on these streamers and now they
don't even get that satisfaction they
put on they're putting like so much work
to just get tossed to the side and to me
that is kind of hurtful it's messed up
to do that I don't even quite understand
is is it like some type of quality
control of uh people because is it part
of I don't understand the mentality do
you know any like analytic algorithm
Deep dive into why they remove it for
because I don't I don't know how it's
affecting the streamer by keeping it up
there I don't know what the server costs
are but I can't imagine six episodes of
Willow is a massive cost and obviously
they removed lots of other shows like
there's I think there was 50 shows
removed one of them was Jeff goldblum's
documentary which I actually watched all
the way through quite enjoyed that the
world according to Jeff Goblin yeah it
was good that was one of like the first
documentaries on Disney plus I think as
well one of their big promo ones yeah
yeah so it's weird to see these things
getting removed and and there's not an
explanation for it really because what
like why do you need to remove it from a
streamer and that you own and the only
reason would be server costs but
I can't see that being a massive saving
no it just I mean especially no one's
watching it yeah tell someone they're
not getting a bonus this year
someone at the top of who we're gonna
put red eyes on in the thumbnail no not
naming any names
um so yeah so Willow was removed from
Disney Plus
the Star Wars Park then closed down now
what are your thoughts on the park you
have you been to Disneyland before
of course yeah have you is there a
Disneyland of course I've never been
here no I ain't got that in the UK
in the UK
no there's no this is one's Paris
wow really you guys don't get one no you
never got one oh never never deserved it
I suppose
man yeah it's her fault
500 videos about her
um
so she so
that closed down
um what do you think the reason that
people just weren't going to that
obviously you know was it made before
the pandemic or was that during or was
it after I don't know we should already
I don't know I I I it sounds like this
is too much like there's only so much
money you can
you need a you need you need to find
that great middle ground would
especially with Disney because
Disneyland is notoriously expensive for
just like admission and everything
yeah I'm sorry
people in England can't even afford it
so they've just built one here
and probably
yeah it's okay after the us we're better
we're better so I was yeah they probably
are
and I was reading that America it was 48
hours that was the longest trip you
could buy there
so you pay the money
no not at Disneyland I'm talking about
the Star Wars thing
yeah this is what happens when we try to
podcast via the Internet yeah
I'm like we're on the same page okay
good because I was about to kick you
there sure they broadcast down
um so yeah something like those you get
48 Hours on the cruiser but the first
five hours or whatever are checking in
obviously you're gonna sleep as well and
stuff's gonna close for the night so
it's not really 48 hours and for the
price you you're paying
it's quite expensive and also another
criticism I've seen
it's it's the sequel Trilogy which no
one cares about
oh really I haven't looked much into it
oh yeah that's a bummer that's one of
the parts about Galaxy's Edge that's not
because they have the park in Disneyland
I'm sure it's cooler in Florida where
it's Disney World like we have
Disneyland out here which is you know
like a junior version I think and and um
I I love Disneyland I do but I don't
really even care for Galaxy's Edge
because it all just yeah
I don't know I mean there's nothing
really that exciting to me about walking
around you know uh the the the Sands of
tattooing you know like when you're
looking at
just basic architecture and then a lot
of it is the performers are placating to
the sequel Trilogy as well yeah like I
don't hate the sequel Trilogy as much as
most people uh but yeah man I'm like I'm
gonna be here I want to see people being
Luke Skywalker I want to see Darth Vader
I want to see some Yoda
um I don't even get a little Jazz about
seeing more Mandalorian but yeah there's
like mainly play it mainly does go to
service the Disney sequels so yeah I I
don't even really care for Galaxy's Edge
uh but they do have a ride there called
rise of the resistance that I hear is
freaking awesome okay I can't believe
I've been to Disneyland man I think
you'd actually really like you got a
family you you would love Disneyland I
probably would but they're charging five
thousand dollars a cocktail you know
what I mean I ain't going you can afford
it I've seen your kids to the park for
free
yeah I mean we probably will go one day
it's just kind of
you know a group or
um and by the time
I made it big oh I had kids you see what
I'm saying so it's like this weird time
of never worked out for me
um and I'll probably get like the crap
beaten out of me because as soon as I
arrive at the park they'll go there's
that guy who made 500 thumbnails about
Kathleen Kennedy with red eyes get him
um so that was that was quite bad I mean
this is like a billion dollar investment
and I don't think that it's been open
that long and for that to close down
that's pretty bad see a lot of people
don't realize with Disney is you know if
a movie doesn't do well there's other
ways that they can recoup money and if
it does do well they also have those
ways as well and the way that they do it
is through merchandise toys but also
these theme parks so say you know
rise of Skywalker I don't think it
passed a billion it came very close but
it didn't but if you build out hype from
that and create a park you know this big
thing at a park where people who watch
that movie then go and spend five
thousand dollars on a cocktail or
something then you're gonna make money
from it but the fact that there stops
bombing more regularly and isn't as
popular that is having a knock-on effect
on the merchandise it's having a knock
on effect on the parks yeah and they are
really starting to see be hit
financially and with it and obviously
the this whole thing with the park
they've spent so much money on it they
won't have made that back in the the
time that it's been open
um and you know that's a big L I I think
I actually think that's the biggest L
out of all of these
uh not Willow getting pulled from Disney
plus not the Indiana Jones score I think
this is the biggest seller and it's
quite a bad one
I think I would agree with you it's the
biggest L because yeah I was thinking
about how
at least with you've ever seen the movie
Water World you should do a breakdown
Paul yeah I love Water World genuinely
like it it was a massive flop that movie
um yeah did not it was a massive flop
but at Universal Studios and I believe
in even in Orlando where the main theme
park is they have a water world live
action show that still goes to this day
it's still one of the main attractions
yeah out of the Universal Studios
experience yeah so even though movie was
like a massive flop it's been like
like 20 something years now or whatever
and it's they still one of their main
attractions at Universal Studios is
getting to see the same exact Water
World show which every time I go it's
still a fantastic it's still a great
show they haven't changed the script or
anything and it's still like a really
really solid show and yeah then they
don't they can't produce that it's like
weirdly water world is it's added
success with that but
um they can do that with this hotel
which is a much taller you know glass to
order here yeah uh but I just I think
the Indiana Jones one
as on podcast segwaying us I think the
uh the Indiana Jones one
is the one that makes me the most
sad uh I don't know how you felt I mean
I I feel more sad for the people who all
lost their their creative works now get
completely shunned away
the one that bummed me out I guess the
most was Indiana Jones because yeah I'm
like I'll have my own opinion when I
watch it if I end up loving it I'll say
if I love it if I ended up liking it you
know uh it it's just the lead up to it
you know at Harrison Ford yeah it's I've
I haven't seen Harrison Ford
be so moved by how he talks about a film
in so long didn't see it with Force
awakens Blade Runner 2049 he seemed like
he was having a blast like having fun
with Ryan Gosling but it wasn't really
about the movie here he just he's like
constantly on the record going this is a
great film this is an amazing movie and
they they nailed it it's perfect and
James mangled it's strange when you get
a movie like this big of an IP even
though he's got a lot of amazing amazing
amazing films under his belt obviously a
lot of people will you know go to Logan
and he followed up with you know 4B
Ferrari which was also really good
this is the kind of thing where you can
weirdly be remembered for this you know
like rather work it's discredited yeah
yeah Ryan Johnson's made his only bad
film is the Last Jedi and that's you
bring up Ryan Johnson and be like oh he
made the Last Jedi but he's made so many
good films since then um and I really
hope Mangold I hope it's good for him
um but it's meant to be really expensive
as well we're talking I've seen budget
estimate they'd never release the full
number
um but I've seen like 350 million for it
and yeah was right so this whole topic
is is basically going around about is
Kathleen Kennedy the right person to be
leading the ship at lucasfilm
first green light and Willow uh I could
have told you that was a bad move
the Star Wars Park setting that in the
new the sequel Trilogy instead of the
original trilogy I tell you Greg if it
hadn't been the original trilogy I would
have went there I would have went to
Disneyland abandon your children
yeah saw them leave them behind it's the
original trilogy they don't know whether
they like stuff
yeah but I mean how many parents are
interested in the sequel Trilogy it you
know the the kids as well the kids might
be but they ain't got the money to be
buying a five thousand dollar cocktail
um so that was a bad decision
debuting Indiana Jones at Cairns
not a good decision
I personally believe I think you're
going to the wrong crowd cans it's like
do you even pronounce it cans or cons
you know it's got that kind of
Aura of pretentiousness around it where
it's a French film festival a debuts a
lot of Oscar winners yeah is Indiana
Jones where they've got it I don't know
if this is spoiling it because it is in
the reviews so let's say this has been
people have been allowed to talk about
this the first 25 minutes of the movie
are the Aged Harrison Ford
so the entire 21st 25 minutes yeah 25
minutes yeah opening that's why that's
why it's so expensive because those
opening 25 minutes are like an old
Indiana Jones Adventure where boards the
age shout all of it
um I've heard that the D aging good and
some bits bit funny on others
um is cans the right place to be showing
a DH Harrison Ford dressed up as Indiana
Jones running around
with then Phoebe willowbridge doing a
Phoebe while a bridge thing
is that the best
place of it because we've been talking
about reactions in this video and how
you kind of want a positive reaction so
you invite all the shills I'm looking at
you Greg getting the shells in he
started saying bad things about Quantum
Mania stop inviting them
um is cancer the best place
him and Kevin Smith have started being
critical get them out here
um so it is
it was that a good decision
no because I think the environment of
it's like when you I think when you go
to Cairns You're Expecting [__] like the
whale uh you know like these super
depressing artistic films that are meant
to move you to tears with its gravitas
and Indiana Jones I don't know who I'm
gonna piss off with saying this has
never really been that deep of a
franchise it's just a swashbuckling
archaeological Adventure I love that
yeah it's a lovely yeah to the old films
like yeah it's Whimsy it's fun yeah um I
forgot what was that genre of old films
that that they hearken to dude what is
the exact words people would be writing
in the comments the three people that
are still watching the video at this
point
um forgot what it's called not
swashbuckling but that word is just
constantly repeating through my head
um Buck Rogers
doesn't matter we'll move on
um um we're gonna totally get what you
mean yeah it's supposed to and while
they can do well I don't know I mean
Kansas already or cons is already losing
its effect with
whatever these like crazy standing
ovations I don't know who these people
are who can stand for like
I I would never clap Beyond like a
minute
um yeah people are like clapping till
their hands bleed I don't know what's
going on with these film enthusiasts
yeah that was like the headline that
variety LED with it was like ooh Indiana
Jones gets lukewarm five minute Applause
it's like they were clapping for five
minutes and that's a bad thing I would
say that's good but some movies they'll
put like their hands hurt from clapping
for Johnny Depp the night before for
seven minutes so you know they gotta
give their hands a break there was some
movie where it was like a 14 minute
standing ovation
um I think that was uh hot hacksaw Ridge
right okay that's pretty yeah crazy
please sir just let me get one minute
more of clapping that's a deep cut
reference
so yeah just seeing the reaction I don't
like Harrison Ford was crying and stuff
[Music]
um
but then you've got the Rotten Tomatoes
score dropping I think it debuted at 52
and then dropped at 33 it's on 49 now so
it's still classed as run again all I
have to do was be better than Crystal
Skull that's all it had to do yeah
and it is sad to see but what annoys me
right is that the Last Crusade ended
perfectly what is the stereotypical
Hollywood ending
riding off into the sunset sunset what
happens at the end of The Last Crusade
riding off into the sunset it's perfect
they've gone back twice you even get the
origin of his name yeah they they've
just I don't get it well I do get it
because I've got no more new ideas which
is why the green lighting Willow Disney
Plus shows
but it's just sad to see you know your
your hero go out on a whimper because
they're not gonna make another one of
these there's no way Harrison Ford's
coming back I might literally go sign up
to run tomorrows create an account where
I'm a reviewer just to get the score up
one percent more just because I feel
sorry for them
I wasn't that closer to I mean I think
Crystal skull's got a positive score
although we're also like rotten tomatoes
doesn't matter but it's all we've talked
about for 25 minutes
um but this is showing that it does
matter
but you know that wasn't a good idea
debuting it there personally I don't
think
no I don't think it was a good idea but
I do hear the ending of everyone's the
common consensus is the first two hours
or like hour 40 whatever is generic uh
Indiana Jones but also kind of sad for
some reason
um and then and then the last half hour
people are saying is gonzo and that's
where a big divide comes in I don't I
don't know at all what they're talking
about
um but everyone keeps saying that the
last 20 to 30 minutes is like a make or
break for you because that's when they
decide to do something very weird
and I it makes me want to see the movie
that during that last 20 30 minutes goes
I really want to see what they do I I
this is probably is this James mangold's
worst reviewed film so far I think so
yeah I can't think of maybe the
Wolverine didn't do that well but I mean
that's a great film
um the uncut version as well especially
that's really really good
I like Wolverine so that's 71 on Rotten
Tomatoes yeah that's fine
what one sorry Kate and Leopold is his
lowest
yeah never heard of it Copland as well
that might be quite low
that's 75 75 I remember you don't like
good movies man that's a good movie I'm
listening
I probably think Indiana Jones is great
um but
it's not a good decision to do that and
I I think if this bombs that they need
to get rid of Kathleen
I don't like saying people should lose
their jobs but it gets to the point
where
you you kind of hit
how many more chances is she gonna get
Disney they they laid off 7 000 people
recently because of ineptitude
are they the reason that stuff's not
doing well over there
because when you look at the higher ups
I'm starting to think uh maybe these
people are losing the jobs because the
higher ups aren't exactly ruining the
show that well everything comes down to
the leadership
yeah
and is she the right person to be doing
this because
the Mandalorian season three as well I
heard so much stuff about that behind
the scenes what was going on I I heard
like crazy things about
John Favreau having so many good ideas
that got shut down and they were
constantly trying to force baby Yoda to
be the Forefront of everything so what I
got told originally was that
Baka Boba Fett was going to be just the
book of Boba Fett
they started making that at the start of
Mandalorian so Mandalorian season two
got greenlit almost instantly they
started working on that and then season
one dropped they didn't realize how
popular that grogu was gonna be the
guy's selling toys he's selling theme
parks he's Disney's number one baby
they realized that they've already you
know got through a lot of season two and
at the end of it he's going off
and I oh crap what we're gonna do to get
him back we need this guy back getting
back so that's where the whole stuff
with the book of Bob Affair where we get
a weird Segway where it tells the story
of manner going to get back grogu
um and that is why he's in season three
and then that kind of from what I've
heard might not be true take it with a
pinch of salt but that is where problems
kind of arose and it was like you're
taking away what I had the vision I had
for this show which was
is going to get trained in season three
but they had to skip over that Arc and
then the whole stuff happened with Gina
where the high Republic show got
canceled but they said they still had
elements of that that they wanted to
bring across into the Mandalorian
and that's why this weird high Republic
elements in the Mandalorian season 3 as
well where we suddenly go off to
Coruscant and spend
45 minutes with Dr Pershing for
something that never leads anywhere and
there's lots of weird things happening
in that season someone is clearly
friends with lizzo as well just [__]
someone's like lizzo shut up and was
like hey I'd love to be in one of your
shows Kathleen he's like whatever yeah
I'm of course you can come down and star
in it strange things happened and you
know you'll notice that fabro's not
really getting pulled into things going
forward Dave filoni's got his his future
movie but there's not that much being
said about Fabro now could this turn out
to be untrue of course we constantly
hear rumors about the Mandalorian that
turn out to be false but I heard this
you know quite early on in the season
and then seeing it play out I was like
you know what makes a lot of sense
and when you think about how popular
That season was
it it does seem like that's kind of lost
you know the appeal it had as well and
I'm just thinking like
the the management Something's Happened
Here where they're they're slowly
running everything into the ground and
this isn't just on Star Wars you know
Pixar's nowhere near as popular as it
used to be
Pixar is pretty much just a streaming
studio now because all their movies drop
bomb and then go hit Disney plus
Marvel's not being as popular
and this is weird thing going on behind
the scenes with it where
Disney are it feels like they're kind of
mishandling all their brands almost when
you look at stocks are tanking too
they're starting yeah it's just so weird
it's the pandemic the the way they
handled the pandemic the reactionary
experience
yeah remember when Christopher Nolan was
so critical of how Warner Brothers was
handling
um the pandemics like I think Studios
they all panicked all around
and tried figuring out weird ass
strategies
strange ripple effect to this day that
they haven't quite figured out how to to
handle a lot of things and
especially you know I I remember I think
the first time it dawned on me when I
was a kid was Toy Story 2. when I saw
that in the movies and then it wasn't
until a year later where it came out on
VHS yeah it used to you used to have to
really wait for something to come out on
physical media
and now everything abides by this 45-day
window yeah and that became even
especially stringent when it came to the
pandemic like you don't really have to
wait for anything and you know it's like
we were talking about leadership I think
Bob chapek
there's a it's like it's the craziest
thing to me in the world how like Bob
Iger did his amazing job with Disney
like bottom line whatever you think
about Disney's decisions he did it he
did a stellar job with like Marvel Star
Wars picks all the acquirements like he
did an excellent job Disney plus was off
to a great success then he chooses Bob
chapek to be his successor and that
seemed to be his one mistake was
choosing Bob chapek and then a bunch of
bad things start happening and you're
right like the Pixar brand especially
that's become exceptionally diluted and
Pixar used to be like Monumental
animation theater going experience and
we have completely lost that with it uh
I mean a lot of people look at light
year but Elementals like as well is not
tracking all that well and I I think
that a lot of like the theater going
experience just doesn't feel like as
necessary for even for me you know I I
kind of got used to the pandemic
obviously with what I do on my channel
like sometimes there's like I'm just
gonna wait till it's out on physical
Media or Digital streaming so I can
react to it or something uh because a
lot of times I don't feel as as
compelled to be going but then you also
look at the product of a lot of these
things and the product of a lot of
things doesn't turn out that great like
everything you were saying with
Mandalorian I think shows on screen you
know like I remember when we first saw
book of Boba Fett
watching a week to week and book a Boba
Fett just wasn't going over that great
after coming off the great season of
season two of Mando so when Mando first
came in I was like we were all like yes
thank you but this is like such a relief
this is good
um but then when I re-watched like
because I want to do a big re-watch
leading into season three I was like
this is just strange and it just reeks
of unconfidence in your actual material
that you have in the season and it feels
like a lack of Direction and it
drastically I think did hinder the
emotional Journey going experience of
grogu uh in in season three and I yeah
what's up yeah it just rubbed that the
the emotion at the end of season two
because it was wrapped up so quickly I
think another mistake they made was
having Mando do two episodes back to
back yeah because I remember it was the
same thing with the Dr Pershing episode
of
um the Mandalorian season three it's
like you're watching and you're like
what is
this the same show because it's such a
weird tonal shift
um and to have that those I think one
episode would have been fine
but to have the break of the week and
then the next week you come back and
you're like oh it's another Mandalorian
episode bit strange
yeah but I just didn't even they didn't
flesh out Boba Fett there was a lot that
went wrong with that season yeah and
yeah it shows and I think John Favreau
every time you check in with him he just
looks more like heavier more depressed
more every time you see him he just
looks more out of it and uh he's still
working here it's Kathleen man pushing
his freaking buttons dude it's Kathleen
um yeah I think I think Bob chapek was
also a major factor is this is gnarly to
me that it went Bob Iger
I'm retired too he done [__]
everything up I need to step back in and
fix everything
in an office on Monday yeah it's
Insanity to me so I have a little bit of
faith that they could fix it because Bob
iger's clearly not been enjoying his
retirement he's just been watching
things fail sucks
like we have that worry as well because
we want to step away from this one day
but it's a case of who do I hand the
reins over because you know there's
there's so much stuff you have to learn
that you wouldn't think you have to know
so I can imagine on a billion dollar
company level that
just handing it over to I mean and
chipak had been running the parks hadn't
he yeah I think so he I mean he was
quite high up you would think he would
be the next in line anyway like the most
obvious choice sure but for him to still
mess it up it's weird but I I think in
general obviously I collect a lot of
physical media and my wall you can't see
here lots of 4K Blu-rays hell of a lot
of comic books I feel like streaming
cheapens things
and it's I don't know I just don't get I
love taking something out that I think
in general just digital things cheapen
things like you know you have a
relationship through the phone you see
people having happy lives on Instagram
podcasting yeah when you if we were
sitting next to each other in real life
we'd probably be having a great time now
you could smell my farts and everything
but it's everything's kind of through us
it doesn't have this physical feel to it
and it does in my opinion it kind of
cheapens things I know people are going
to be like okay Boomer but there's so
much content at the moment
um you touched upon Frank Grillo before
and I was watching an interview with him
on Michael rosenborn's inside of you
with Michael Rosenberg and he he he's
obviously worked for Marvel
he's worked for DC and they got into
what the hell is happening with the MCU
at the moment and Frank was very Frank
about it
it was Grillo in what was happening and
he was saying
he just said there's too much of it and
that there is that's true there's no
anticipation anymore oh do you remember
how you felt waking up the morning of
the one division finale getting to cover
this I was I was so hyped I was like oh
my God I can't believe it and now it's
just like oh well it's another Disney
Plus show finale gonna get into it
there's just been so much stuff and I
think
they have greenlit far too much and
they've realized that as well and that
they're slowly pulling I I think that
Disney hit a point right like we we know
lots of YouTubers who run channels and
there's this corporate mentality
that more is better because more will
make more money and we know a guy who he
worked for a channel for years and years
and years he built it up to be this
massive thing he had an incredible month
and the the channel was owned by someone
and he he was managing it but he he
built it up himself and instead of being
like wow that was an amazing month
the person was like why aren't you doing
this every month and their the corporate
person's idea was
we need to do more videos
and he was chatting with us
um behind the scenes and stuff and
asking what our advice was and we all
said
you need to explain to this guy that
more videos doesn't mean more views
you're gonna dilute the brand there's
going to be too much for people to watch
and it's it's difficult to have people
constantly coming back all the time like
I'm doing a hell of a lot longer videos
now and one of my big worries is these
videos are too long for people to watch
more than one a week and I do see it
sometimes in the views
um and I think I made the wrong decision
there
but you know we we are self-employed we
make mistakes and
Disney I think have done a similar thing
where the mcu's been so popular
they chapex come in and being like
you need you guys need to make more of
this it was very much a phase four
mentality where I think Marvel thought
everything we put out is a banger we
made Guardians of the Galaxy popular
let's just make EV let's make a show for
every single character make as much
money as we can and the entire time they
weren't thinking this is over saturating
the brand and it's not making things
special anymore and Frank Grillo was
saying this is too much
well
at first I was like I don't know maybe
it'll be fine
you know because but then as things
started to happen what I didn't factor
in and maybe you know there's a lot of
negative rhetoric around Echo season one
getting everything and dropped at once
and maybe it's true frankly that's where
my mind went like they must want people
to really forget about this [__] as soon
as it's like that's where my mind did go
that it might be like really bad yeah
however you know what a big thing is you
gotta miss something so that way you
haven't and nothing drives more
viewership I think and and butts in the
seats than creating great anticipation
like that that then they say you sell
the sizzle not the stake that feeling of
anticipating I think that's why our
trailer like my trailers do so well is
because that's a feeling that people a
lot of times when something comes out we
stop talking about it it's just the way
it goes yeah something's out we talk
about for the weekend and it's done
um but a trailer creates creates a
conversation in hype and anticipation
and when you don't get time away and
especially if not every product is is
like a banger if every product is like
yeah it's just mid now compared because
before
okay how would I put it we had so many
movies it's not just we're getting so
many movies it's movies and shows so
that's even more if you're getting like
three shows and three movies a year that
is way more time committed than six
movies in a year because now you're
spending like weeks with a one property
and then now it's like move on to the
next then weeks with a property then
move on to the next so you get even less
time to miss the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because you are committing to
these television shows now so I do
wonder if the echo series
has something to maybe do with that
because they are like releasing Marvels
around the same time Loki as well
there's a lot coming out so as opposed
to making you feel like but then again
I'm also going maybe maybe it's just
because Echo might might not be good and
they just want people to kind of forget
about it and they might have seen like
there are some shows that just don't
have the week to week value yeah um so
yeah I think I think because they didn't
factor in that when you're doing all the
shows as well you're especially not
going to give people a chance to miss it
if it was like only movies it might
still be a lot but it's very different
feeling than when you have to consume
eight to ten hours of television as well
yeah now they released some finales on
the same week as they released movies as
well I'm yeah like 100 sure that the
Hawkeye finale released the same week as
no way home because there were people
saying do you think Spider-Man's gonna
swing by the Hawkeye finale because
they're both set in the same place I'm
like no you idiot they're not gonna
waste a appearance of Spider-Man on that
because Sony only let them have him for
about six projects or something but that
at the time being like
an MCU thing on Wednesday an MCU movie
on Thursday it just it feels more
draining for people I think that they're
having to organize their lives around
these films when it should be
oh man I haven't seen this for so long I
can't wait to do it and it's like oh
I've got to watch this thing to keep up
it's a bit of a chore and they've had so
many projects where the people aren't
big names they I genuinely think in
phase four I think God into the Galaxy
was one of the best things that happened
to Marvel and it was one of the worst
things to happen to Marvel because it
showed that they can take any character
and make them you know a big name which
is a good thing obviously but the bad
thing that comes from that is that you
know you can't take every single
character every single time and just
have nothing but
d-listers constantly rolling out all the
time like everyone people say you know
Iron Man was a c-lister and stuff the
original Avengers team there were some
c-listers amongst them but there was
also the big names as well Incredible
Hulk that is a big name massive in the
70s the TV show that guy can sell solo
movies himself the universal haven't
used them properly but there was a
reason that Universal just bought the
rights to the Hulk and not the other
Marvel characters because the Hulk
cancel you know he he is a big name he's
like Captain America massive name
so you know Thor Iron Man they weren't
massive ones they were your c-lister
sort of things but they were packaged in
this big team up with these household
names of Captain America and the Hulk
now you look at the other stuff that's
been you know Ms Marvel's not household
name
Agatha hawkness isn't a household name
echo's not a household name Hawkeye at
this point yeah but then you're saying
well it's actually Hawkeye Junior hey I
think Haley steinfeld's a bigger name
than Hawkeye
um but it's not it's difficult they feel
like rather than spacing out these
lesser-known characters and padding them
amongst the big names they're instead
saying no you're gonna get lots of
lesser known characters and you're gonna
get to love them and people don't care
that much
they they're they're interested in the
overarching story which is why things
like Captain Marvel can come out and do
a billion because it's sound which
really nicely in between Infinity war
and endgame
but we don't feel like we're building to
anything at the moment I know we've got
the Kang Dynasty coming but there's not
that massive killer thing and I think it
was a mistake to not have phase four end
with an Avengers movie I know you know
part of the narrative is they're taking
a break from Avengers movies because the
Avengers aren't assembled at the moment
but you know you kind of need this
uniting Force to make you feel like oh
well I need to watch these lesson on
characters
um and once what you just said about
that to sorry to interrupt that what you
said about that about is I've heard like
Kevin feigert or someone said that right
about Avengers not being assembled at
the moment the movies haven't made that
clear
because the last time we saw Avengers
they were all [__] together like they
were every single one of them was an end
game it was massive and this this idea
that they're not assembled together is
not something that has been made clear
uh to the audience I think like they
even bring up The Avengers sometimes and
so that's that's a big part of what I
think is also missing is that when you
when you train your audience for
connectivity and then you start seeing
the none of that's like you know that
it's eventually leading to something
because and that's why they had to
announce [__] uh but it does yeah but I
think they need to kind of make that a
little bit some of the things they need
to clear Us in on and what you're
talking about Guardians as well is that
one of the lessons they did not take
from it was and you could kind of see it
with
Avengers and event and Age of Ultron is
how if the first Avengers movie felt
it's still a committee movie but it
still really felt like they let Joss
weed and actually have a little bit more
rain and then you see Age of Ultron
which felt more like committee
interfering and that's a movie that
destroyed Joss Whedon and James Gunn
they let they yeah it takes his like
characters were not as well known but
they really let him have his own voice
with it yeah and I think that's
something that's missing when you're
taking a lot of these uh it's like
famously you know uh Edgar Wright walked
away from Ant-Man or because of what was
happening there and I don't really know
what Peyton Reed's unique voice honestly
is I I don't it doesn't really show even
though he's directed all three I don't
know what his unique voice truly is and
um and and I think even with some of
these movies and shows like I think Miss
Marvel was really doing I I actually was
there's a lot about Miss Marvel that I
really liked and I think the first
couple episodes had had a really unique
voice especially like that's where I
felt they let those the guys got fired
from Batgirl um those guys I I think
they really let their voices shine
and then then you get something like
She-Hulk where it's kind of split yeah
I don't I don't have I feel that they
want to have their voice but they're
also being kind of told how to do this
and that's why I was okay with the
finale especially because it was like
well [__] it they're kind of going Hog
Wild here so just at least that's
different you know so yeah
um and and I think that's a lesson that
a lot of them don't really uh Embrace is
let them have their own voice and I
think that's where quantumania so
especially failed with audiences is it's
just you're starting to feel these
movies that feel like chat gbt wrote
them you know yeah and that kind of
takes us on to our next topic which is
Jeff loveness apparently out of Kang
Dynasty hell yeah which
I it's all his fault all his fault that
makes sense that's what I was gonna say
next I think I feel like he's been made
to be the full guy I think so Ant-Man
came away Michael Waldron was made to be
the Fall Guy from multi versus Madness
yeah it's crazy to me when people like
oh Waldron ruined it he took Sam raimi's
like he took the original script that's
Scott Derrickson what had in he he
rewrote it and ruined it it's like well
do you not think it's the studio who
which the green like that and got him to
redo this script that also takes some
blame in it like there's people who you
know Sam raymie admitted to not watching
One Division or something and I'm like
you're directing the sequel to that
there's but I like Multiverse of Madness
it's like I scored it and nine out of
ten or something at the time and I will
defend that movie to the Grave I think
it does a lot of big things and people
just people on hip to it they're not hip
to that style
um but Waldron uh sorry
yeah sorry my bad he's taking
so much slack for quantumania and uh so
I rewatched It on Disney plus last week
with the imaxing the 4K Blu-ray came
yesterday finished watching it today
there's not good things you know that
that is there's issues with it right but
the Kang scenes I think are really well
written
um they're very tense they've got a
great and that one with Michelle
Pfeiffer and Jonathan Majors where they
rebuild the ship and she's kind of
telling the story I think that's one of
the the better scenes that we've had in
the MCU for a long time there's just a
very good undercurrent to it of
um you can kind of with her discovering
Kang's villain it works really well
um anyone who comes out that movie you
know you speak to them even if they hate
it they'll still say that scene is good
so I can totally see why they're getting
they had him to write Kang Dynasty now
he's not out officially yet but it's
looking that way
he's just taking the Flack for all this
I I think he's done better than what
I've seen from Peyton Reed I mean I
didn't really like Ant-Man and the WASP
I thought the first Ant-Man was great
but you can kind of see that Edgar
Wright did a lot of the groundwork for
that
but he's Peyton reads fine and to me the
buck stops with him you you either you
know the the script can take you to a
certain point and then you kind of
figure out what works and that what
doesn't I mean there's so many directors
who've taken scripts and been like well
we'll cut this we'll edit this out blah
blah blah yeah so it's sad to see him
kind of taking the heat for everything
do you remember that we bought that fan
a ticket for Quantum Mania it was like
oh I can't afford to go and see it and
Jeff loveness was like don't worry I'll
buy you ticket so you can go check out
the movie that seemed like a nice guy
thing to do doesn't negate that there's
problems with Quantum Mania but for him
to be
you know the Public Enemy Number One
right now is pretty crazy to me well
that's the shitty part about being a a
writer
um
honestly if if uh if the movie was
really well received I don't think
anyone would talk about how great the
script is like yeah no one ever no one
ever really does they talk about the
director and how great the director did
um but then when a director and I'm not
saying it's only the director's fault
like clearly there's a lot of factors at
play here that are you know the studio
interference and and the the committee
uh making a movie uh rhetoric that goes
around with these films
but at the same time writers rarely are
the ones who are accredited unless they
wrote and directed the movie they are
rarely the ones who are accredited
unless they're like Aaron Sorkin or
something where like reveal the script
really sings Through the um yeah but
most of the time they're not and most of
the time it's the director gets all
their credit and a lot of times if a
movie sucks they blame the writer you
know so it's a sad thing and a lot of
people don't realize like these movies
go through especially it's not like some
independent film or a mid budget film
there's a massive Blockbuster so they go
through so many different stages post
the screenplay and there's a lot of like
crazy you know they talk about the VFX
artists who are constantly being like
drilled and having to rework [__] and
that happens all the time too with these
big movies is they're constantly being
told
to to rewrite stuff and change stuff con
as a part of the movie making game even
on smaller films you got to keep
rewriting and keep writing the script
never really ends but a lot of times
it's like who's giving this note to
change it who's trying to like fix it
like I don't think I think at least
there was a consistent voice with with
Ant-Man and Ant-Man and the WASP but I
think Peyton reads voice whatever that
might be is not present at all in
quantumania like I don't know what this
distinct vision is that he could have
for it and Jeff lovedness to be getting
all this slack for it I'm like guys
there's so much that went wrong with
this movie it is it has not come down to
just freaking Jeff loveness's script was
was the script like what was that first
script that they decided to go with and
maybe that was great but so many things
changed along the way and they often
change things while they're while
they're directing it while they're
editing it you know there's a lot that
factors into it and to just blame it on
the screenplay itself is like yeah the
screenplay that I saw was not great but
he is not so fully responsible for it
and that is not the thing that it's it
you know I I don't know I just can't
like even with Indiana Jones and dial of
Destiny one of the writers on it is
David koep uh who's written a lot of
amazing films I believe he's the writer
for Jurassic Park you know yeah and I I
so these guys are in some great [__] but
once in a while you know it's
it doesn't come down interference yeah
there's a there's a lot that happens man
and uh it sucks for the guy it sucks
well they say a movie's made three times
once on the page once on the set and
once in the edit and he he shows a
factor but what I mean what is the what
are your problems with Quantum Mania for
me it's the third act where stuff just
kind of devolves into
the usual stuff of Marvel which is
that to me that's on Marvel because they
do that sort of Trope so many times
where it's like we need to ramp things
up to a big battle one of the best
endings I think to a Marvel film is
Doctor Strange where they don't do that
and they just have strange going
head-to-head with Thor Mamu who figures
out a way to trick him and torture him
by keeping him in a loop of time until
he gives up and it's a draw
that is clever to me but Shang Chi as
well I think the third Act of that just
kind of love it up to that point but
then it just kind of goes into weird the
under dwellers here
um Quantum Mania I just kind of feel it
turns into trying to be a New Hope
doesn't really work that well and
originally they did have a different
ending where Kang won
um and this has been this has been said
so many times that you know it's not
officially verified but
when you get sent a plot league and 90
of it is right up until that ending then
there has to be some weight and Merit to
it and we do know that the film was
re-shocked because we've seen the what
originally was there um behind the
scenes stuff so I think that the
problems that that film has are sort of
the ending I think the first act's
really good when you know Scott's
narrating his life and stuff and
everything seems great and then when
they go into the Quan realm kind of
falls apart Modoc what the what the hell
is going on with Modoc
the when they send what's the
probability realm they send Scott to
that I think that's a great scene but
the way that it they handle the
resolution of it of shoot that thing to
make it smaller didn't work just shoot
it again I think that's weak and then it
kind of goes into this third act thing
where it's
everyone just going all out with these
characters that you don't really care
about the the whole Rebels thing doesn't
really work from that point onwards for
me so I think that the the the the
effect of quantumania why it really
is bothersome is because that third act
after probably pretty much like right
after the probability realm sequence and
moving forward
is it actually
negatively affects the acts that came
before it with realizing there's not
much impact or weight with anything that
came before it yeah where it's not like
it's not like how we're talking about
the Wolverine movie where you're like
those first two acts are amazing and
then the third act uh is a wonky third
act where but like I still walk away
with the Wolverines first two axes like
I really enjoyed that experience they're
back a little weird I really enjoyed it
same thing with Wonder Woman right
um but yeah the quantum Mania kind of
makes the whole thing when you look back
on it feel like weightless the entire
time which I I think is more of a you
know Trope of the genre more than
loveness writing a bad third act I think
he probably just called Toe like uh just
whatever just make a big fight scenes
have Cassie get big because she needs to
learn how to do this have her beat modak
have whatever I don't think that's so
much in loveness to be honest I think
that's a lot of different factors like
one of my big things with the film is
that it looks like it's just really shot
on a green screen if you compare it to
Avatar 2 that feels like a lived-in
world and no it's all CGI it feels like
the characters are actually moving
around and interacting with that world
and then you move over to Quantum Mania
which
it just feels like everyone's standing
in front of a green screen in the
background Michael Douglas man
that ain't that ain't yeah he doesn't
even look like he's on set nothing to do
with Jeff loveness that ain't not that
nothing to do with him so lay off the
guy yeah leave Jeff loveness alone
just apparently he's been taken off Kang
Dynasty and I think this spells that
we're gonna get lots of delays with
Marvel coming up they might even change
that I can't rewrite it
they can't do anything
um but that kind of takes us into
Jonathan Mages as well which is another
big problem for Marvel at the moment
um though they've never really addressed
it
apparently he got taken off the
marketing for Quantum Mania I mean he's
on the steel book but apparently he's
been a really downplay that he's in the
film and for this guy to be such a big
part of the phase going forward I mean
we're gonna see him again this year as
in Kang and Loki and he's apparently
playing multiple Parts
um you know you've got the post credit
scene at the end of quantum Mania where
he's playing Victor timely but that's
one version of Kang that's gonna appear
he's not gonna be the the only person
that appears they're gonna have so many
different versions of them and the fact
that they have a date locked or Loki
season two
that says to me that they're not
reshooting
they know it it's coming out this time
so Kang will be played by Jonathan
majors
and now I kind of feel like they've
looked at the whole Ezra Miller
situation and sort of
seen that people
you know they they say they care on
Twitter but when it comes down to it
people are still going to watch it Papa
John's yeah papa John said a lot of bad
things mate but sometimes yeah I buy
Papa John's Pizza when I feel like a
nice little pizza you know what I'm
saying you've got to separate the dough
from the man and I think that they've
seen with Ezra Miller that as outrageous
people are on Twitter
it's not worth completely scrapping
these things it's not worth doing what
they did with like at the start of the
metoo movement there were so many people
fired
and they saw a lot Hollywood would have
lost a lot of money doing that because
they would have had to reschedule things
recast things
um get in diff audition people and stuff
like that
and I think they've seen with Ezra that
Warner Brothers just kept quiet having
changed the thing and they've realized
that as crazy as Twitter's is and seems
all manic
the way you might not have to do
anything we'll see how things play out
but we can probably still get away with
releasing Loki season 2 because it's
been filmed and one of the big defenses
of the flash when people like why
haven't why haven't I ever shot this the
the big defense is like well you know
it's so difficult to reshoot that movie
it would cost so much money that they
they're just gonna put it out there
and I think low-key season two they're
just gonna keep things as they are
you know Mages is still going to go
through his stuff he he's not getting
into the Limelight for a long time
they're they're doing what they did with
Ezra where he's not going on press tours
we're not going to be in trip
interviewing the guy they're just
keeping him away from the production
probably the marketing is going to be
heavily focused on Loki
and that'll be it what so what do they
do Greg Kang Dynasty did actually did
you see the other day that they almost
there was a statement put out saying
well you know can he we weren't building
the next phase around him actually there
was some person that Marvel
who said they would that Kang was never
fully meant to be the focus which is
complete gaslighting because I tell you
the guy was definitely meant to be the
focus when you call them films Kang
Dynasty and
you know Secret Wars so people have
taken that to be like well they might be
introducing Dr Doom or something because
he was originally the person behind the
The Secret Wars that they're they're
basing things on
um
so what do they do they keep Mages even
if
he's found guilty or do they recast or
do they make it in different villain
I I think
I think Marvel finally learned something
from DC with how they're handling this
it's the first thing I think uh I think
if Kang Kang is found guilty if if
Jonathan Majors is found guilty a
hundred percent they should recast if
he's found guilty like yeah no if sounds
or butts about it they should totally
recast him I don't think you need to
because at the end of the day
I feel like you could still recast King
I I still yeah I think you can
definitely character for it as well he's
that's it you know like he he is just
the whole idea behind him is variance
and you don't even have to really do all
you don't even have to go down the route
of like explaining any of that [__] just
get a different guy like you you can do
it you you can absolutely do it and
I think it would be more distracting if
Jonathan Majors was like a massive
a-lister at first and then they put him
in there but a lot of people became
familiar with Kang who Jonathan Majors
through King the Conqueror and if you
look at his screen time that we've had
with him so much it's really not
as much as people probably think like
he's made an impact but it's not as much
as people actually think we've spent
with King the Conqueror
so and and on top of that too King got
his ass whooped an Ant-Man in the WASP
quantum mean yeah ridiculous but by the
very end of the film and so we got rid
of that King you know and then you could
just read and while we had the whole
Coliseum effect and it was all obviously
Jonathan majors and sure we'll see him
in Loki season two
it wouldn't be that
difficult I think for people to readjust
considering the fact that we have
while while they have established that
like all the variants apparently look
like Jonathan Majors
we've also established that there can be
variants that don't look like Jonathan
they don't even have to go down the
variance path I think there's already
like like they already established that
there's already Spider-Man variants and
none of them look alike you know
45 year old man exactly so you can do
the same thing with Jonathan Majors
where where you don't even have to
explain you don't have to try to explain
it away you don't even have to try
anything I think you can definitely just
recast him I think there is so much
it's a fascinating thing to see what's
happening with Jonathan Majors it
because he was it was Peak like
stardom you know two number one hits in
a row where he is the antagonist and he
is the talk of the movie both movies in
a row where he steals the show from the
set from the main character yeah both
movies and then to have this downfall is
crazy and yeah innocent until proven
guilty all that jazz there's there's so
much surrounding this right now though
and I think it is he is lucky that
they're like yeah we're gonna fire the
rider King Dynasty so this is gonna get
even more delayed so it's gonna give you
time to buy yourself out of the
situation yeah I I I think I think too
weirdly another effect that could happen
because you know even on my end as
someone who's done like some Ezra Miller
videos I have found myself going I
wonder what their performance is going
to be like I I do I get more curious
about it you know yeah and I think it
sucks because I think you're Jonathan
Majors you can it might work better to
its effect that you don't promote him in
Loki season two because when he shows up
you'll just see him as king the
Conqueror and you won't yeah have that
Association you'll be even more excited
that he's there so I think it'll
actually work in their favor
because yeah because I mean he's such a
good actor that's like what why I'm
saying like it sucks and stuff I'm not
saying it's sad because like this guy's
getting done for stuff like obviously
man if he if he comes out that he did it
really bad and what's sad is that you're
gonna be
he because he is he's a brilliant actor
you cannot take that away from and
what's sad is that you're going to be
watching this thinking
man he's really good but I feel bad
because he's just a horrendous person
you know what I'm saying it's like sure
it's it's difficult to fully switch your
brain off to it and enjoy it when it's
got this air of
you know and it this happens
knowing things behind the scenes can
always affect the way you view things
like Ahsoka is going to be very
difficult to watch for a different
reason which is the passing of Ray
Stevenson
um and then Loki season two is gonna be
difficult to watch because you you know
all the stuff that's gone on behind the
scenes with that as well and
it's it it's all like I try and stay
away from this stuff I kind of learned
my lesson by covering the Johnny Depp
trial and there's so much you know there
was there was lots of crazy things going
on with that and I wish that I hadn't
really waited into it and now I'll get
people messaging going how come you know
how come you don't cover Ezra Miller how
come you don't uh Jonathan majors and
I'll say like oh well I'm I'm just kind
of staying away from that and they'll go
the views won't be as good
well exactly but I mean that hits a
point where it's even if you were
getting views it's not worth it and
there'll be people like well
I'll say look I'm just not covering them
go but you covered Johnny Depp it's like
well I kind of learned the lesson from
covering that trial that there's just I
shouldn't personally wait in on this
stuff because everyone has so much
baggage with it and you you see the
baggage with 200 the Mages as well where
you know it's people talking about
there's people who think that he's Being
Framed by Hollywood because he's a
successful black man there's people who
think that he's a target of these women
who want revenge there's people who
think that he's a high profile man so
he's getting away with taking things out
on women there's
you know there's the Marvel fans who are
like oh we want Kang we don't care what
he does like
everyone has has so much baggage with it
that I don't feel like I can accurately
represent those feelings and come off
where I don't sound like an idiot
because there's so much stuff to wait
into which is which is why I don't talk
about it
um
except for like these 20 minutes on this
podcast but
I said this yesterday on Twitter
if they can recast House of the Dragon
the two main characters in that during
the season really quick uh I mean so
they can't cast anyone sorry to
Interruption there's it's that
the thing though too when you recover to
come to your defense a little bit here
is that when you recup when you're
covering the giant depth stuff
that was a trial there was like yeah
yeah actual was in trial of information
and documentation and witness testimony
that was being publicly
presented you know
um I was like I've done a couple of
videos about Jonathan Majors I don't I
don't go like hardcore serious in them
um same thing with Ezra Miller I've
given my opinions about everything's
come out but I've
I've skipped a lot of Ezra Miller stuff
and I've skipped a lot of stuff
because it gets to a point where you're
like well I've already said what like
here's how I'll feel if this happens
here's how I feel if this happens but
then day I'm like well we now it's at a
point where we just gotta kind of wait
to see what happens now like what really
happens now other than just what's you
know just being speculated on and so
yeah that is different for
especially for like your kind of Channel
which is so much about like getting the
[__] information and people rely on
you for that you know yeah it is
different to cover that instead of like
a giant up trial
and even like the Will Smith slap stuff
I know there was people at new rock
stars who wanted to cover that and
um
they didn't and looking back I think
that was the right decision not for them
like they shouldn't cover it not to be
like you can't cover it but I think it
again that came with so much baggage you
remember
um when I when I covered that and was
talking about it I played a clip from a
guy who was kind of just talking about
his thoughts on it I was like well
here's what this guy thought not
thinking that the guy who was saying it
was black and then I had people
messaging me going well you've you've
used him because you'd you feel like
you're you're propping up him as the
only voice I can speak on the situation
because of his skin color and I might
didn't think of that at all he just
offered an interesting and well thought
out opinion and I think people do bring
their baggage with this stuff
to the point where it's difficult to
navigate it it's a lot easier for me to
talk about an Easter egg in a comic book
show than it is to break down all of the
the things behind what's happening with
Jonathan Majors right now but I I think
you know people who are like well you
can't recast I think you can I think he
can recast anyone I mean Harrison Ford's
playing he's taking over William Hurt
um and I think I also think that people
turn a blind eye to certain things like
you know there's some stuff with William
Hurt I remember saying but when he died
I remember saying rest in peace and
instantly I was getting hit with tweets
saying well didn't you know he did this
and he's like
it's very difficult to navigate without
you getting pulled into a lot of the
negative
things that people have done
um and I think I think Marvel's playing
it smart though I honestly it you know
all all things you know considered
they're actually taking the best route
right now they're just waiting and
seeing yeah like not if you remember
like the whole James Gunn thing they've
fired the guy crazy
uh you want to come back you know and
here
it's like yeah there'll be a uh an
official verdict within court and then
there'll be the court of public opinion
and because some stuff will come out and
we'll see you know it's like OJ was
deemed Innocent but everyone thinks he's
guilty so if that's like yeah it could
be a similar thing we're like let's see
how many people likes in in public
opinion and I'm not just saying that
because OJ's black I'm just saying that
that's what happens sometimes and
sometimes people are proven innocent in
in court but then in court of public
opinion too many people still are
against them right and that could be a
case for Jonathan Majors or it might be
nah man this the what happened there
that does show that John the majors is
actually innocent so they are they are
actually taking the smartest route right
now instead of just firing him and yeah
like just kind of hiding his name and
promotions is the best thing you can
really do and waiting for the trial to
play out yeah well that I mean that's
what I was saying with me too there was
Studios even in accusation I mean there
was that guy who got fired from some
studio because the staff were saying he
he hugs people quite a lot and he's a
bit kind of creepy which he I don't
think yeah
might be yeah I think it was John does
John Landis I forget not John I mean I
don't want you to say who it is and it's
someone who's done something really
horrible and I'm sitting here going yeah
that great guy great guy but there was
definitely some people who got fired for
stuff that was you know what I mean it
was a bit like overreactive like
there's so many people
um that I feel like I'm gonna it'll kick
off if I get into it but there's so many
people who they they reacted very
quickly to I think when Warner Brothers
did the whole thing with Ezra where they
would just saying oh whatever just never
gonna acknowledge it pretended flash is
coming out we've shown it to Stephen
King and he loves it
um I think when they saw that worked and
that it's not really had a massive
negative effect on the film that they've
just thought well it's pointless
announcing things now
um look how much firing James Gunn
messed us up as a studio because that
did have such a knock-on effect Thor and
Guardians had to switch release order
and they were having to divert plots
from certain films into others to cover
that uh and it was it was a mess I can
imagine it was big scramble behind the
scenes especially for them to get to the
point where they had to go back and
rehire him and he's of course he of
course in that time when he was you know
didn't have a job where did he go work
at the bloody competition that and he's
now going to be running as um as the
main competitor to your universe so
they've I think they learned their
lesson from that as well and thought
well if we get rid of Mages
are just gonna hire him anyway they've
seen with Ezra they can just do what
they want
so yeah it's very very difficult
situation to navigate but we'll see how
it goes when is the trial very soon
isn't it I think it's not till I might
be getting confused with the writers I
think it's it is either June or July but
it's definitely soon it's really soon
it's the same day as Loki season two
releases
yeah but moving on to the next topic so
yeah that kind of takes us into the
writers strike in general which is the
big thing on at the moment David zazlev
did a speech at Boston University don't
know if you watched it but I I gotta say
you know whenever people say
person was booed at commencement speech
or a person was booed at speech a lot of
times I'll like look up the audio and
I'll go I don't are you sure you know
like when people said The Rock was booed
at Comic-Con like you kind of have to
really look for it you gotta have to
perk your ears up a bit yeah
this is David zazlov [__] no it's like
the entire crap
plane flying over like this is crazy I
even felt uncomfortable for him as he's
like powering through this speech about
being kind and respectful to the people
who work for you and it's just yeah
giving a speech and people look so close
to where he is
be given a big speech about and people
start doing it and then you look up in
the sky and there's a plane flying
the scenario that yeah yeah that was
very real man that was it's like
impossible to miss like you don't have
to look for it it's right there
that would make me so embarrassed that I
would go home and yeah speak to the
union guy I'd get him on the phone and
go look mate I'm sorry I messed up what
what do you guys want we'll try and come
to a a resolution on this you're not
going to get everything you want we're
not going to get everything we want but
we'll try and get to a point where this
benefits both parties
um I mean
it's weird watching the writers strike
discourse because there's some people
who just hate what Hollywood's been
putting out at the moment going good I'm
glad that
not getting paid much but I think if you
hire someone to do a job you should vet
them and if they do the job you should
pay them and then you kind of deal with
it from there you shouldn't then be like
well actually it show wasn't that good
so we're not gonna give you the money we
agreed to
but there's so many things involved with
it
um streaming shows are a lot shorter now
so right is when they get hired they
don't get kept on for as long so say
back in the day you know Walking Dead
used to have 24 episode seasons
writers would have a steady job where
they're working for 24 episodes that's
quite a lot you know keeping your
paycheck coming in every week it a thing
that people don't talk about with actors
and
um writers is that
it's not you're very you're very much
self-employed and you're having to go
and Pitch yourself to Studios for why
you should be writing this show you get
hired and three months later you might
not have a job Russell Crowe are
watching an interview with him where he
was talking about
um working on Neighbors which is a soap
opera in Australia and they were kind of
joking about with Russell and saying oh
it must be so weird you've had this
massive career and then there's people
who were working at Neighbors when you
went on as a guest for three episodes
and they're still there 40 years later
or whatever and Russell was like no but
I totally get the mentality because as
soon as I finish a film even I now think
am I ever gonna work again and that's
the thing when you're freelancing and
you're not exactly signed on as a
full-time job or have a permanent
contract you are very much worried all
the time that works not going to be
coming in so if you got given a 24
episode episode season you thinking oh I
can take a breather for a while I know
this works coming in and then after the
season finishes they sell that show on
to other networks across different
countries for example you guys in
America you make shows that you show on
certain Networks
our TV stations and so on over here
we'll buy them and then we'll show them
so they get money from selling them to
us
and those residuals keep coming in on a
streaming service you haven't got anyone
to sell it to and the episodes are
shorter as well so instead of doing 24
episodes you're doing six or eight or
ten and you're not having to sell it to
people in England because you've got a
streaming service out that's worldwide
so they're not getting the residuals
from that either and a lot of these
people are actually when they've looked
at it they're working for less than
minimum wage
and they're not asking for a ridiculous
amount of money
they're just saying can we have enough
to get Buy on and maybe a bit to enjoy
ourselves there's this weird mentality
that's come out of the pandemic with all
the strikes and stuff where people are
thinking
oh you you should get paid just enough
to live on you shouldn't have enough to
buy
Funko pops and enjoy yourself you should
you know you're asking for way too much
money and when you look at what they're
asking for it's not really that much
it's not gonna improve their Lifestyle
by a massive amount it's just gonna make
them slightly more comfortable and
they're not going to be as stressed
about money and when you're going from
different show a different show
it it makes sense because these
streaming services are killing it
even when they lose subscribers they're
still pulling in quite a lot they can
afford to get rid of Willow you know I
mean well even like um
when you look at you know like what are
some like Last of Us and and House of
the Dragon a lot of people don't watch
it on HBO they waited for it to go on
HBO Max
um they would watch it there so even
their like big
televised shows a lot of the times
especially if it's some form of basic
cable the premium cable they wait for it
to just go on the streamer to watch it
there and so yeah the streamers are are
mainly the the source for
a lot of these things like these writers
also they basically I what I believe the
breakdown it's been a while since I've
heard it but that I think there was a
big disparaging difference
between like what the writers were
asking for would essentially cost like
400 something million dollars and what
the producers countered with was like 80
million dollars worth
so it's like what the producers really
offers like five times less than what
the writers want but a lot of what it
was coming down to was
making the environment feel more
supported and and uh more trusting
because they basically want people they
basically want freelance writers they
don't want to just hire anyone
permanently to work on a show and
they want more depending on the number
of episodes of a show they want a
guarantee of how many writers are on the
staff like a a lot of the times when
people might not realize is you know if
if a show says written if there's an
episode that says written by this person
more often than not there's a lot the
writing team is is all involved in that
you know it's like this is someone that
writes the script but then everyone else
has their input on it as well like it's
a really good creative process uh that's
generally how how it goes so they need a
good writing team especially depending
on how many freaking episodes you're
delivering because you are putting a lot
of pressure on people you know there was
those stories coming out about what was
that uh was it reservation bear was that
do you know what that show I'm talking
about something reservation you couldn't
even go to like the to go attend to
receive receive his award because he
didn't make enough money to be able to
pay to attend uh for it like they want
to just hook him up with us yeah figure
out what the show is crazy
um so I figure what it's called
reservation dog no no it's Reservoir
talks but anyway the it's so there they
want that basic needs met they want to
be able to be paid properly and be
guaranteed like how many episodes you'll
be on it they basically just want like a
better contract like something that is
more suitable and of course be entitled
to better pay on residuals but I think a
lot of the so I was talking with someone
uh as a producer I was talking with and
he was saying how
if they feel that you know like one of
the most notorious things about
streamers is they don't release their
numbers they like never release their
numbers because if they did I mean if
you look at what you know Disney's just
recently done HBO Max did it as well
when they just make a bunch of shows and
[__] vanish you'd see that a lot of the
numbers are terrible for so much of what
they do
and we want to be able to see those
numbers because then that helps out with
figuring out the compensation of the pay
and all these things that were
everyone's trying to negotiate
um but I think you know these streamers
are afraid to release their numbers
because now I just make their stock
plummet even more Yes except for red
nois which red notice was the biggest
move of all time biggest thing ever man
19 million 19 billion people watch that
or something yeah
now another big headline floating around
about the writer's strike is that AI is
going to be taking over their jobs
GPT has made a big splash recently and
studios are starting to think we can
just get this to write our entire movie
and then hire someone to come in and
clean things up which I think I think
once you hit that point with Humanity
you might as well just let Skynet drop
the nukes on Earth because that's it
done I've always thought fair enough AI
use it for the jobs that people don't
want to do but creative things like
making art or writing stories you know
creating is part of the The Human
Condition it's our soul you know yeah
I'll I will back in the day I don't do
it as much because I'm just working a
lot but back in the day I just used to
get out of pen and paper and just sit
and draw wasn't a show to anyone but
just because I found it relaxing and
enjoyed sitting and drawing stuff
now ai art that I can type something in
it'll make an infinitely better picture
than I could ever sit and draw but the
enjoyment that I used to have from doing
that is gone and it's the same with
every single thing I think that this is
such a part of what makes us human and
it's an expression it's art
having a studio and having AI do it I
think
you're handing over the keys to what
makes us us and just giving it to a
machine to strip us of everything I I a
dread the day when we go and watch
something that's just written by AI
because
I said this the other day as well on
Twitter and one of the responses was but
like what about morbius and stuff like
that where it's terrible
and I would rather have a discussion
about how bad something is and how it
hasn't worked and what the flaws are and
maybe there's some good bits in it I'd
rather have that discussion than I don't
see how I could have that about a piece
of AI work because all that boils down
to is you've put the wrong prompt in at
some point and it's generated a script
that isn't that good
that that is literally the the criticism
that you could have oh the AI didn't
figure out how to give this guy proper
dialogue that that's terrible but maybe
they'll get in next time you know what I
mean whereas I think when the movies
yeah when a movie's bad or a script's
bad you can at least
have a discussion about it and there's
people who built entire channels out of
just tearing things apart and
criticizing it which I would rather
watch someone tear something down than
just have a bit of AI art or an AI
script that you can't really criticize
or talk about the expression in it I
think it's so short-sighted for Studios
to be wanting to do this
maybe you can use chat gbt to write your
breakdowns for you
I know someone who tried to do it as
well there is a YouTuber out there who
was experimenting with doing it
um it was a corporate channel so they
have owners who again they're constantly
trying to save money and
be like can you not do this more quicker
and we don't have to pay our staff
anymore we don't have to pay people and
I think that they did look into having
AI generated scripts having AI generated
voice over and
AI edits as well
so the entire thing would just be
handled by a machine it's too much
yeah it is
how can you as a viewer how can you
attach yourself to that you're gonna
it's gonna click at some point and
you're gonna think
this um I don't have a personal
attachment to this we've been talking um
recently about shorter well one of the
reasons that we decided to launch this
podcast was because the options were
either short or do podcasts and YouTuber
clearly starting to realize a lot of
companies have have realized that shorts
and so on there's not much money into
them
um so they've started building things
around podcasts and so on which is one
of the reasons we thought you know what
we can just do one you go on YouTube now
and try and upload a video you'll see a
section that says create a podcast they
are clearly doing this stuff because it
realize there's no money in short form
content and there was a guy who did
196 million views and got like two
thousand dollars which is crazy because
the amount of people that would have
watched that is and to not have ads on
it but I'm getting off point there
so the the this there's another reason
why I've kind of brought this up is
because people attach themselves to
personalities and it's difficult to do
that with a short you've got to be
someone like like soups is a great
example of someone who's managed to
build a channel and a brand off the back
of shorts whenever you go on is Tick
Tock he's in the frame you you click on
his page you can see all the pictures of
him
um and the the headlines are kind of
what you read and what makes the videos
different
I couldn't do that because I just do
voice over a lot of the time and it's
difficult to build a personality and I
think doing that as a video on YouTube
as well
No One's Gonna attach themselves to just
an AI creation Because We crave personal
interaction almost you you have
parasocial relationships with people
where you feel attached to them like
we're always talking about
um Mr Sunday movies and Nick Mason and
what they've done brilliantly is that
they you feel like you're part of the
conversation with them and I can't see
that happening with AI I just can't see
it happening
no I agree no one's John Connor and
Terminator two you know what I mean
they're not gonna think that the T100
800 is their dad I I would be more this
is the part where I think I would be
more interested in working with AI like
on a creative like on a truly creative
level or watching like one of these
hosting things that you're talking about
like we're going AI gung-ho they're the
host now
um if they really let AI just become
some type of sentient being if they let
it just become a creation like if we
were in the stage of the movie
artificial intelligence with like Haley
Joel ostman and uh and Jude Law because
then there will be a soul to it then it
would be something that was truly
created from Humanity like just another
form of some kind of crazy child but you
know the fears that were always going to
be you know in Skynet and [__] and and
people taking over
um you'll get replaced yeah I remember
probably being replaced yeah uh by
Humanity being replaced so yeah I'm like
but if there was a way where it'd be
like what if we just had like some good
AI if there's a way but then you'd have
to control it right but we have a we
have a natural fear it's like the same
thing about you know uh when we think in
science fiction about aliens coming to
visit us it's always they're coming here
to destroy specifically New York City
they're coming here to like kill us all
for some reason good um instead of maybe
they just want to visit us
you know
um and so I do I do one maybe because we
that is our own perception of humanity
and then like they would see how hum
it's our own fear that they would see
how corrupt and messed up humanity is
that AI would destroy us I I would
be more I still would be more drawn to
like oh no this AI I see as another
person I see as a soul
um yeah if they get to that point but
then a lot of the lessons that they're
going with AI is to save money it's not
it's someone at a corporate level again
we keep talking about this this is the
theme of the podcast someone at a
corporate level who doesn't understand
the creative saying well why can't you
just fire everyone and just get AI to do
it you know what I mean it's not what's
the best and most creative product it's
but we can save money by using Ai and
fire everyone can't we
this I'm sure there's some
um there's some Community where they
have a special thing where it's you buy
from everyone else in this community if
someone sets up a shop I'm butchering
this right now but if someone sets up as
shop or sets of a business even though
it's a little bit more pricey might be
more expensive you buy from them because
they're part of your community and
they'll then put the money back into
your community and I think that as a
species we should just boycott
everything AI so if someone makes Mobius
too and it's going head-to-head with
Spider-Man no way home to if Spider-Man
no way home 2 is written by AI as a
species we should just come together and
go no we'll give money a Mobius too
that's where we need to support
ourselves before the AI takes over
I I love I because I write you mean you
know I've talked to you about that
several times like I love writing that
is one of my favorite that's arguably my
favorite thing to do where when I'm
really in the groove I really feel like
this it's the one time I'm not aware I'm
I don't look at it like I'm working at
all even if I'm doing it for work
purpose when I'm really doing creative
writing right on a story or whatever I
love that feeling and and I I don't
think I could ever that's part of it is
like the creative reward of doing it
yeah I will say
um from dabbling with chat gbt what I
think is good that could work with it is
sometimes I'll I've I've used it as a
form of Google just to get better like
quicker research out of the way like
I'll give an example
um I wanted I was working on the thing
about vampires and I was like I just
told chat gbt and then say write this
story for me I said tell uh give me a
list of a bunch of vampire strengths and
weaknesses and tell me about them from a
bunch of different movies and put it in
the list so then I just organized it
into like 10 to 15 characters and it
gave me like their strengths and
weaknesses and it allowed me to pinpoint
what the commonalities were between them
so instead of going to Google and then
like typing it in and then making a list
on a Word document I just had chat gbt
do it so that way I could just see it so
to me the times I've used it have been
mainly for just like a quicker like the
first time I used it I was like [__]
around a lot I was like write me a song
in the voice of Eminem like I was just
too stupid
yeah I just wanted to see like how crazy
can this thing go and I have found with
messing around with like story stuff
that it does there is an artifice that
it does it's like it often leads with
like
the cliches right you know it's pulling
from a lot of that and sure you can
guide it and whatever
um it to me it does Rob with the
experience I don't mind using it when I
am like I I just want to like make the
research go faster so I can get to
actually writing quicker you know like
that that to me is fine if I'm just
quickly researching it but yeah if I'm
not gonna
because like that kind of shits is like
for my own notes
um yeah so it's not the screenplay
itself so I guess yeah like I said it's
getting out of it's getting the jobs out
the way that you don't want to do which
is what I think AI should do you know
everyone kind I don't think I don't know
any machines you know my Alexa she I
don't feel like she's angry or feels
like she's being enslaved you know what
I mean so I feel like using
AI to do jobs we don't want to do is
totally fine unless they get angry one
day and they they decide
I want to just sit about on the couch
all day yeah that's not the guy who's
becoming like existential and
contemplating life yeah I want that AI
so I think that's fine but I think when
you start taking away the creative side
of things the actual creation
I think that's you stepping over the
line and it's gonna mess things up the
more and more you rely on it because I
just feel like the biggest imposter
honestly I would feel like everyone does
yeah like Oh you mean
no I mean like imposter syndrome is like
a thing we all saw all most of us deal
with right but I would not feel
it would totally take away the the
pride and joy of of like doing the task
you know like if I just [__] dropped
it into a machine and said like write it
for me uh yeah I would totally
understand if it was well received
what was that saying in school if you
cheat you cheat yourself or something
like that there's a chance to that
there's a massive truth to that you'll
know deep down that you ain't [__] and
that imposter syndrome's gonna get worse
and worse and worse yeah I'm gonna take
it out on your wife or some [__] you
know so
she doesn't exist because I kept sitting
around with the AI all day so she left
oh well yeah it needs via the AI
so that was our final topic but you is
anything else you want to talk about got
Godzilla anime show that's just been
announced or no Skull Island Paul said
we're gonna do an hour today yeah it's
two hours now but yeah I mean I'll tell
you what I was like I'm not going to
interrupt Paul we're gonna we're gonna
do the whole well I'll end when Paul's
rated in yeah well I've had a I've had a
fun time anyway you know if I was going
for a run this is the kind of thing I'd
listen to
so I appreciate you letting me just talk
to myself whilst I go for a run but yeah
thanks everyone for checking this out if
you want to support the channel or me or
Greg we're both wearing Zero edition
shirts right now if you go to
xeroedition.com you can get your hands
on one of these they are very high Fab
but very high quality fabric
um they're not just cheaply thrown
together the prints are really good you
can do that the print's not going to
mess you can wash it as many times as
you want we're very proud of this
merchandise it's not just been something
we've done on the cheap so go to
xeroedition.com my Link's gonna be there
Greg's Link's gonna be there Ryan Harry
bloody Ryan Harry where's he at today
not here but we're still pushing his
merch because we're bloody good mates so
yeah this has been the first episode of
the real Spoilers Podcast we're
available on all podcast things I think
it should be but if you if you can check
us out on YouTube Spotify I'll try and
get that out if I'm not then message me
saying why the hell on you on Spotify
Apple podcasts I'll try and get it out
so we hope you've enjoyed just sitting
with us chilling
talking about nonsense
probably got a lot of things wrong
probably said a lot of stupid things as
well let us know below and we'll see you
next time where we'll be back to talk
about
across the spider verse I think so yeah
when do you see it
um not for a while
not this week but the week after next
Thursday so I think we might skip a week
because if there's nothing to talk about
a good start and how much Greg enjoys
sitting listen to me ramble on for two
hours but we'll be back don't you we
feel like the number one thing we always
tell new YouTubers learn to be
consistent
first way off we're skipping the next
week we'll we'll continue following well
it'll be a nice surprise when we pop up
next week with a brand new episode just
before across the spider-verse about
Kathleen Kennedy should be fired yeah
it's 501 videos now
so we'll see you next time take care
peace